In my last video, I discussed some
patterns I'd noticed during my time
reviewing decks. And there, I gave five
common deck building mistakes that I've
seen people make. However, that video
only covered some of my observations,
with the other thing I calculated being
how often I suggested adding more of
different types of cards to a deck. And
after interaction, the second most
common element here is a tie between
lands and ramp. To be honest, this
surprised me a little, particularly the
ramp part. Adding ramp feels like a
somewhat dated suggestion to give
somebody. A tip offered to newer players
in 2018 for how to keep up with the
competition in the hottest new format on
the block. In 2025, card draw and
synergy feel like bigger focal points
for EDH critique and where players
should be focusing with a trendy hottake
these days being that people run too
much ramp. That the focus on ramp of the
past decade has gone too far in some
cases. And undoubtedly there is probably
some truth to that. Ramp has become an
accepted part of basically every deck.
And adding ramp to a deck without
thinking about why you're adding it is
both a commonplace action for people and
a recipe for decks that aren't as lean
and powerful as they could be. And yet,
there have been nine decks that I've
seen that I thought needed more ramp as
opposed to only six that needed more
draw. So, in this video, I want to get
to the bottom of that discrepancy and
hopefully build a framework that can
help you tell if your deck is in need of
ramp or in need of something that's not
ramp. The first point that needs to be
made is that ramp spells don't fulfill
one single task. Rather, they perform
two separate functions. Curving out and
increasing total mana quantity. Let's
start with the first one of those. What
I mean by curving out is deploying your
cards in an order and on a timeline that
lets your deck best perform his game
plan in the first five turns of the
game. If we consider a dinosaur deck as
an example, most Pentalaza players would
probably prefer to get him out on turn
four since dinosaurs played after him
generate extra value and dinosaurs
played before him do not. If we assume
that most ramp spells ramp for a single
mana, this means that we need to choose
whether we want that ramp to happen on
turn 1, 2, or three, or what mixture of
these values we'd prefer. Let's map out
those different options. With a turn one
ramp spell, we skip two mana and have
turns with three and four mana. In
addition to the turn four pentlaza, with
a turn two ramp spell, we skip three
mana and have a single four mana turn
before our five mana pentlaza turn. With
a three mana ramp spell, we have one and
two mana turns, but skip directly to
five without a four mana turn. So, how
do we make our decision between these
different options? On a basic level, it
might just be coordinating with the mana
values of the non-ramp cards. If I have
lots of four drops I like and not many
two drops, adding a bunch of two-cost
ramp works out well. If I have some
setup plays I want to make with two mana
and not much on three or four mana,
adding some three cost ramp likely works
well with that. There are a couple other
factors though, such as that some ramp
will simply be better for our deck than
other ramp. Ramping on turn one is
theoretically the most mana efficient
from a mana spent standpoint. But
basically all one mana ramp will be in
the form of mana dorics which could
amplify the weakness to board wipes that
already exists for dinosaur decks.
Meanwhile, though three mana ramp is
less mana efficient and takes up an
often contested mana slot, it's also
likely to have upsides beyond just
boosting us up one mana and additionally
might contain more cards that synergize
with the rest of our game plan. If we
have lots of great plays to land on
three and four mana, that one mana dork
might still be great. But it's all about
weighing the risk versus the reward. And
there are plenty of decks where the
reward won't be great enough. One final
consideration is how tap lands affect
our curve. If you build the most
optimized possible mana base, you could
probably mostly avoid these, but this
may not even be necessary. Lots of mana
curves build in a bit of breathing room
where they can play a tapland
consequence free, often on turn one, but
also on later turns as well. With our
hypothetical dino deck, I'd expect a
pretty normal curve to be nothing turn
one, a ramp spell turn two, a three mana
card turn three, and pentlaza turn four.
And that curve gives us two different
places to play a tapped land. Budget
players rejoice. So that's curve out.
The other function of mana ramp is to
increase the total amount of mana a
player has, agnostic to the timing of
any one card. The easiest example of
this is high-cost commanders. You might
run some ramp to curve into it in the
first place, but if you have a six or
seven mana commander that poses a major
threat, command tax is probably going to
be the bigger factor that compels you to
ramp. A deck with a high 30s land count
is naturally going to start missing land
drops around turn six absent any draw or
filtering. And even if you manage to hit
every single land drop, the escalating
cost of a commander can get pretty
painful to keep forking over. So this is
the other thing ramp does. It works
alongside an X land count to keep total
mana increasing. Aside from an expensive
commander, there are a few other reasons
you might want to keep your mana
increasing. One is that you're playing a
deck with a lot of card draw and other
ways to turn through your mana, but
where your game plan isn't all that
fast. In principle, spending more mana
is a good starting point for trying to
win EDH games. Though, there will be
differences in how much mana is required
to win. Some decks will be lean and
proactive enough to be able to win by
spending only 20 mana, where others
might take 30, 40, or even more than
that. If you're just getting started
with a new deck or even just getting
into the format, a good starting point
will be to aim high with both draw and
ramp since you might not know the amount
of mana you need to win. If it ends up
being higher than expected, you'll be
glad to have a deck with more draw and
ramp whose game plan is volutrically
larger and prepared to play later into
the game. As a final precaution, if
increased maximum mana is the role of
ramp you're leaning into, you're going
to be best served to prioritize more
permanent forms of ramp, preferably land
ramp, mana rocks in a pinch, and mana
dorks at your own caution. An Elvish
Mystic will be great for a buttery
smooth curve out, but an EDH game is a
hostile climate for a squishy guy like
that in the long term. So, these are the
reasons why you might want to play a lot
of ramp in your deck. And I do think it
is helpful to start by laying them out
like this. However, this still leaves a
couple other questions on the table. For
one, how much ramp should a deck be
running, assuming it wants it in the
first place? Well, if we're talking
about ramp for curveout purposes, this
is a thing you can quantify pretty well
ahead of time. Figure out your target
you're ramping to and the appropriate
mana values of ramp to get you there and
then shove some values into a
hypergeometric calculator. You can find
such a calculator on my website linked
in description, and you can also use one
built into a deck building website.
Looking at my Rata deck, you can see
that Architect gives a 77% chance of a
ramp spell playable on turn three in my
opening hand with 18 copies in the deck.
And this is a comfortable figure for me
since it's a type of card I'll always
want. You can also tweak the cards drawn
parameter to match the amount of cards
you've seen by a turn you'll want
something. Though, only do that if
you're okay keeping hands without it.
Also, if you don't want to do any math,
here are some benchmarks. 18 cards of a
certain role, like we see here, is a
good number if you always want to see it
in your opening hand and are okay
getting multiple sometimes. 15 is a
healthy total if it's a tool you want
every game, but there's a bit of wiggle
room for alternate paths or maybe some
early filtering. 12 is nice if you want
a tool in most games, but have some
alternate options for curving out. Nine
is good if a thing is a frequent part of
your curve out, but not a core part. And
finally, six is good for if you want a
thing sometimes, and three is good for a
thing that you don't really want to draw
very often at all. All of this is for
the curving out purpose of ramp. For the
total mana function of ramp, it's going
to be easier to feel it out than
anything else. My sharroom decks ramp
suite is pretty narrow on paper, but in
practice, it feels like just enough to
let me achieve a mana advantage in the
late game, which can be really helpful
for a control deck that wants to
outscale opponents. Relevantly to the
point here, that Goldilocks total was
the product of dozens of games feeling
out the deck's needs. However, that
advice might not give you any helpful
information in the here and now. So,
I'll now pivot to answering a second
question that might offer a bit of
insight. When does a deck not want ramp?
Conveniently, the answer to this
question is kind of just the inverse of
the two reasons for wanting ramp I laid
out earlier. Let's think about mana
curve. If you're playing a deck with a
lot of important lowcost plays, you
might not have a turn where you even
want to be playing a mana rock. I have a
Maria Voltron deck that is packed with
one and two mana equipment. And since
I'm building around a three mana
commander, that means my turns one
through three are already spoken for.
Going purely by the standard of
curveout, this deck wouldn't want any
ramp at all. However, I do still run a
decent quantity of mostly equipment
based ramp. And that's because this deck
always always wants to be able to pay
commander tax. My commander is a big
part of my value and my plan for
winning. And her Özaike presence is
massively important to the deck's mana
economy. While being a three-cost
commander helps in recastability, I
still like to be able to stockpile a bit
of extra total mana just in case I end
up needing to recast her. So, this is a
deck that doesn't want ramp for curveout
reasons, but does want it for total mana
reasons. For a point of contrast, we can
think about a deck that doesn't want
ramp for either of these two reasons. My
Malfagore deck runs very little ramp,
and looking at its game plan, it's not
too hard to see why. My curve is
heaviest on three followed by two mana
with most of these being either engines
to build in value or discard spells to
strip resources away from opponents.
Since I don't really have consistent
four or five mana plays, a mana rock
would do absolutely nothing for this
deck's early game. Importantly, this
deck also doesn't need total mana. The
goal of it is to push all players,
myself included, into a low resources
state. And even with a draw engine or
two up, I'm still not going to be
drawing that much mana worth of stuff
since my curve is moderately low.
Previous iterations of this deck had a
lower land count, and ramp felt useful
there for casting the commander. But
I've since come to the conclusion that
consistent land drops are really all
that's needed to keep up with Malfigor's
command tax. So the total mana reason
for ramp just kind of evaporated with a
few extra lands in the mix. I mentioned
earlier that high counts of draw and
ramp is going to be a solid starting
point for a lot of decks, and that is
true, but as you get a feel for a deck,
you might find that your counts can be a
bit lower. Maybe your deck is more
efficient and simply needs less mana in
general, or maybe your deck is like my
Malfagore deck, not necessarily wildly
fast or powerful, but also not looking
to pump up the scale of its gameplay a
whole lot, even in a late game scenario.
As a final point, let's get back to the
idea of lands being a replacement for
ramp in some cases. This is an idea that
has been bubbling just below the surface
in EDH discourse for a few years now. A
couple of extremely talented Magic
players, Frank Karsten and Sam Black,
have each weighed in on this
relationship, and both came to the
conclusion through use of simulations or
other mathematical means, that the
average EDH deck would be served well to
focus more on land count and less on
quantity of ramp. While I would hesitate
to endorse the exact numbers they've
come up with, or really any exact
numbers given the many layers of
complexity in the commander format, the
fundamentals of the critique still hold
true. A lot of ramp and a low land count
is frequently a recipe for inefficiency.
Now, land count is an area where a lot
of commander players have shifted in the
past couple years. No longer are we in
the era where 35 to 36 lands is
universally accepted as a good starting
point for an X land count. Still, the
inertia of the previous eras of
Commander Wisdom still means that a lot
of players haven't followed this shift.
One might ask, are they justified in
this? Well, sometimes. Some decks just
don't need that many lands. They don't
need much mana to do what they want to
do. They have options for early
filtering that can find them more lands,
or their deck benefits enough from
maximizing gas that it's worth it to
sometimes miss a land drop. An example
of this I gave in my lands video at the
start of this year was pseudo storm
commanders such as Joyra Weatherlight
Captain. Whether or not your deck is
justified in running a lower land count
for one of these reasons might not be a
simple judgment to make, but here's a
basic test you should start running.
Whenever you miss a land drop with a
piece of ramp in hand or a piece of ramp
that was recently played, make note of
that. If that is happening for you every
game or even multiple times per game,
that's an indication that you probably
need to swap some ramp spells for some
lands. Thanks for watching and thanks to
Architect for supporting the channel.
Architect's tools for visualizing
categories make it a lot easier to
figure out questions of lands and ramp.
How early does my draw and filtering
come online? About that early. What does
my curve look like after I cut out the
instance I know I'll be using reactively
rather than playing on curve. It looks
like that. A link to my decks is in the
description if you want to play around
with these tools on decks I've built. I
also want to thank my supporters, some
of whom are on screen now. If you want
to join this illustrious crowd, you can
become a YouTube member or sign up for
my Patreon. With that said, I hope you
have a lovely new year.